we were both so kidded me holy [ __ ] man
I'm not playing anymore bro I'm off this
game I'm sorry Tim I'm not playing
anymore today I'm sorry lost this
[ __ ] game bro so uh he's not
exaggerating
[Music]
you might have noticed that fortnight is
kind of fallen off over the last couple
of weeks it's not consistently the
number one game on twitch anymore
usually hovering somewhere around third
or fourth and meanwhile people are
jamming World of Warcraft classic like
it's 2004 and over on YouTube people
can't stop watching Minecraft videos
turns out epic [ __ ] up again and they
just happen to do so at the worst time
possible for that so let's start with
the beginning way back in August
fortnight launched our season 10 update
and brought mechs to the island the
mechs called brutes are these giant
two-person robots with one person
driving the robot and the other person
manning a shotgun and missile launcher
to fend off attackers the issue is that
brutes [ __ ] suck to play against see
when the mechs launched the missile
launcher they came equipped with did a
stupid amount of damage they were also
super mobile and in a weird insane twist
basically they could be piloted solo
with one person jumping between the
driver and gunner seats they could also
tear down buildings which meant that
they could gather resources faster than
anyone who just didn't happen to find
one meanwhile there are enough in every
game that it felt pointless to try to
take them down look it's really cool
that they put Gundam knockoffs in
fortnight or whatever but imagine trying
to take that thing down with a shotgun
you are going to die every single time
let me put this in perspective
epic [ __ ] up so bad that the hashtag
removed the mechs was the number one
worldwide trending hashtag on Twitter
the Friday after they came out epic has
nerf brutes
over the last month but it's never been
enough and the fact that matter is he
were designed to unbalance the game they
were built as a crutch for people who
struggle with getting kills and victory
royale
just the mere presence of the mechs has
terrorized fortnight's player base and
look I don't really play fortnight I
think these things look cool but I'm not
a serious for an AI player and for them
this [ __ ] sucks the Faculty's insanely
overpowered over centralizing mechs are
terrorizing and unbalancing the game is
enough reason to remove them and Elise
from arena fortnight's dedicated
competitive mode well you're making this
video epic actually removed mechs from
fortnight's only to add the back a day
later basically people were super happy
for about 24 hours until everything
sucked again you already see encouraged
react but he's not the only one who got
pissed enough to stop playing fortnight
so some of the biggest things in
fortnight are pissed off at the game
EPIK isn't budging this is all happen
before but the mechs were the last straw
people wouldn't pissed off about foreign
and mechanics in the past but this time
people packed up their bags and a move
to Azeroth while classic was pretty much
a perfect gift for twitch streamers in
the days since its release asthma gold a
popular Wow streamer has overtaken Tipu
and shroud as the most popular streamer
on Twitch
meanwhile shroud us out here saying that
Wow classic is costing him subs and his
girlfriend is saying that he spent hours
playing the game off stream and it's
pretty easy to understand why people are
obsessed with WoW classic I didn't
scream I didn't stand up I just was
staring at the screen and tears are
rolling down my face nostalgia is really
powerful powerful enough to get people
to play a 15 year old game that kinda
sucks now okay where's the rest of these
mobs oh no got disconnected
oh my guard just says population high
now
Esmond I'm staring at 300 minutes dude
no no no no all right and all
seriousness I get it a hundred percent
understand why people would want to go
back to vanilla Ezra and I definitely
understand why people would want to
watch some old school Wow on twitch when
fortnight the previous biggest game on
the platform sucks to both watch and
stream but the other game that's taken
off some a fortnight's heat and
experienced a pretty crazy resurgence is
minecraft surprise [ __ ] anyway I
don't know exactly why minecraft is
popping off right now but if I had to
guess I'd say it's probably for a lot of
the same reasons that while classic is
doing so well nostalgia this makes me
feel old as [ __ ] to say because I
remember when minecraft came out like it
was yesterday but if you were seven or
eight when the game came out you're
probably like 17 or 18 now I don't know
I'm bad at math but you're nostalgic for
the game of your childhood and now you
probably have enough money to buy a
realm and play the game for real and
yeah PewDiePie is playing Minecraft
again but I don't think he's the only
one responsible for this explosion we've
got courage playing it on YouTube hey be
sure to crack up this is being serious
that's how many I got 69 I'm
we've got a ninja playing on mixer and a
bunch of people suddenly playing it on
twitch again I'm not just making all
this up over the last 30 days
fortnight's of viewership on twitch has
dropped twenty point five percent now
it's still the most streamed game on
twitch but less people are watching and
even that number is dropping four day
was streamed for nearly 4.5 million
hours over the last 30 days but that's
actually twenty three point eight
percent lower than where it was in the
previous 30 day period meanwhile WoW is
the number one most watched game on
twitch up one hundred and seventy eight
point eight percent and minecraft is up
in the top five of most streamed games
so is four and I said I don't really
know I have to imagine that epic is
gonna vault the mechs when season ten is
over but the precedent here is pretty
weird every other time the community got
this mad about something epic got rid of
it but this time they're holding firm on
one hand I respect sticking to your
convictions on a design choice it takes
a lot of guts to do that as a game
developer but on the other hand it seems
like mechs are pretty clearly eating
into fortnight's of viewership if not
its player base so what do you think is
for tonight dead if so is it good
riddance or is this just a hiccup in the
unstoppable dominance of the game that
our comment section hates more than
anything let us know what you think and
I can definitely understand why people
would want to wash some old school Wow
when minecraft the previous game but I
feel like that new power do you see that
new Pokemon the one though it's like the
[ __ ] mission it's a mouse definitely
look at a [ __ ] hilarious
if you punch it too hard it shoots its
fish at you
okay
[Music]